サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン エータンブッダナサーサナン
ではよろしくお願いします
えーと 今日はブッダの友情論というテーマになっています
仏教は一応友情の教えであるという副題で
友情っていうのは大事なテーマになっていますが
友情論にしているんだから
テーマはね 私は友情論を語らなくちゃいけないんですね
まあ普通はまあ そんなにお釈迦様は友情論というものを教えていないんですね
戦友であることはとてもありがたいとね
言っていることですからね
では 無理やりお釈迦様の言葉を友情論にします
まず あの なんか私の椅子見えませんね
どうなってますか？まあ無地黒で見えるでしょうね
椅子のスライドの色が薄くないね
えーと まずもちょっと誤解する言葉がいくつかありまして
たくさんありますが 一つ二つ紹介します
仏教ではこのエーカビハーリーという言葉がありますね
だから本物の人はエーカビハーリーであると
意味は孤独で生活する
何の人間も人間関係もないという
一般的に意味になるんです
お釈迦様がエーカビハーリー孤独生活を推薦しているならば
友情論なんか何なのかという風になるでしょう
この単語が誤解しているんです
世間で仏教学者の世界では
知識として仏教を学ぶ人々は
結構いろんなところを誤解していて
あまりにも学問とかね
自分の肩書きを強引に出しちゃって
それは世間に一般一般的な仏教になってしているんですよ
でも本当の意味は違うと思いますよ
そこで次にパーリ語を出します
エーカビハーリー エーカワイビハーリーティ
バンテ ブッチティ キッタワタヌコ
バンテ エーカビハーリーホーティ
キッタワタチパナ サードビハーリーホーティーティ
意味は孤独で住むとは何？二人で住むとは何？もっと美しく
日本語パーリ語でありますよ
孤独で住む 孤独で住むと言っているんだよ
どのようにすれば尊師
孤独に住むことになるのか
どのようにすればもう一人で一緒に生活することになるのかというのが全文の訳なんですね
これは省略しました それでお釈迦様の答え
長いです お釈迦様の答えはすごい長いんです
大きい経典です 長い経典です
で 省略すると ゲンニビ出身に接近
意に好みの色相こう民宿法が触れる
知ってますね 我々の目耳鼻にいろんなものを触れると
いいなと思うものはあるんですよ
これは仕方がない 例えば
ちょっと飴を口に入れちゃうと
いい味だなというふうに思っちゃうんですね
で 鼻を口に入れたっても
いい味とは思わないでしょ
対象を好むとナンディが生じる
それで対象を好む 例えば飴玉を舐めてて
ああ いい飴ですね これはメーカーは何々メーカーでというふうに
この対象 この飴を好んでしまうんですね
ちょっと評価してみるんですね
そうすると ナンディっていうのはすごくなんとなく
さらに興奮感 喜びが生まれてくるんです
あまりナンディっていうのは
お釈迦様は特別単語で使っているんだから
私はちょっと丸括弧で楽しみと書いたんですね
なんで行く楽しみでもないんだけど
まあ好む ああ これはいい
これはいいということで
その対象に行っちゃいますね
お巡り買ったっても 自分がローソンで買うか
セブンイレブンで買うかね
座ります なんとかマートとかね
そういういろいろ買っていってると
何か 1個あ こっちの方がいいやと店見たらローソン
あ これからローソンで買おうということになるかも
それは対象を好んじゃったんですね
だから その時に生まれる気持ちがナンデーというんですね
ナンディアーサティ サラゴーホーティ
楽しみから愛欲が生じるんです
今 飴玉の例で出したでしょ？飴玉舐めてみたら
誰だって美味しく感じますよ
だって人間だからしょうがないでしょうに
それから あ これっていいね
この味はとか 気に入ったとかね
言っちゃうでしょうね
それから愛欲が生じるんですよ
サラゴーサティ サンヨーゴーホーティ
愛欲から執着が生じる
それから自分の気に入った飴は
それからも買いますね
店いろんな種類あっても
あれ選ぶんで あの種類
私の好みはこれですよとかね
私の好物の飴はこの種類だよとかね
そうなっちゃうんですね
だからもう束縛が生まれちゃったんです
サンヨーガっていうのは執着と書くんだけど
この直訳は結ぶ 結ばれてしまうんですね
対象と結ぶ つないでしまうんですね
ナンディーサンヨージャナサンユットコーニガジャーラビッブクソドゥティエヴィハーリーティブッチェティ
このお坊さんの名前はニガジャーラなんです
ニガジャーラ 楽しみという愛着が
愛着がある比丘が二人で生活しているんですと
ちょっと微妙な意味ですね
今 飴玉の例に言ってみてください
もう飴 何々メーカーの何々種類の飴玉で自分がもう繋がれているんですね
二人ですね 対象と自分
例えばローソンのおにぎりが気に入った人が田舎に行ってもローソンを探すんですね
あーローソンがない ここら辺でもうもう大阪辺だったらローソンじゃなくてファミリーマートでしたっけ？ファミリーマートばっかりで嫌だからもうなっちゃうんで
す
もう二人でいるんですね
だから仏教がいう二人っていうのは
夫婦でいる意味ではなくて
対象と一緒に仲良し生活しているんですね
はい それで経典の後半は私は抜けたんです
意図的にページ数も決まってますから
それで比丘が目に入るもの
耳に入るもの 鼻に入るもの
舌に入るもの 体に触れるもの
頭に入ってくる概念などについて
好んで対象に引っかかっていかない場合は
自分だけ一人なんです
例えばローソンのおにぎりを仕方
まあ一応美味しかったよ
これで終わり  で ファミリーマートの方に入れる
これはファミリーマートに行けばまあこんな字ですよ
まあそこはないんだけどねという感じで
自分で判断する場合は
まあ私個人で判断するならば
自分好みはローソンだと言っても
ベースにローソンでなければ死んでしまうということはないんですね
いるで そういう人々 あの品でなければ
あのブランドでなければ絶対ダメという風にね
特に女性の方 あるんですよ
もうそれでなければダメ
あのあの店でなければダメとか
これ 2人生活じゃなくて
これはもうあらゆるものとつながって生活してるんだ
それは苦しみなんですね
精神的に落ち着かないんで
それで比丘がまあ どんな人間にも阿羅漢であっても
雨は美味しく感じますよ
悟ったら雨が苦くなったことはないんです
でもただ甘さがあって
美味しく感じている はい
なるならそれだけ それ以上はいかない
それは孤独生活なんです
それで誤解しているでしょう
孤独といった途端 閉じ込めて閉じ込まれて引き込まれていることだと思っているんですね
そうじゃない 普通れるんです
これはすごい精神的なことなんです
仏教的人は誰にもそれ説明してないんです
例えば森に住むとかね
空き家に住むとかね そういう単語
結構あるんです お釈迦様はこの修行をする場合はね
こういろんな弟子たちに
特に自分の親戚の方々にざっと説法して
私の仕事終わった 師匠としてやるべきことをやった
まあいくらでも木の下あるでしょ
空き家があるでしょ 墓場があるでしょって言って修行してなさいと
その言葉で物の見事に勘違いして
出家たるもの 仏教の修行者たちがみんな墓場に生活しなくちゃいけないとかね
森の中に生活しなきゃとか
社会嫌いやとか いい加減にしろと言いたいんですね
じゃあ座って瞑想するとね
いろいろ 例えば子供たちが来て
もうサッカーやっているとボールも当たるわ
面倒くさいでしょうに
それだったら墓場に行って誰も来ないんだからね
それってちょっとしたことですよ
我々も勉強するところ
自分の部屋に入ってドア閉めるでしょうに
それ家族嫌いになったわけじゃないでしょ
でしょ 勉強する子供が自分の部屋でドア閉めて勉強している
あ あの子が家族を嫌がって嫌がっているんだよと言える？そんな話でブッダに侮辱
ブッダは侮辱しています
次の単語はドッカというね
ドッカは日本訳は空なんですね
これ真理大事なんです
ブッダが発見発見した偉大なる 4つの真理の第1なんです
だから真理は空だったら
仏教はなんでしたっけ？悲観論だと
へっちゃらで言うんです
もしかすると仏教学者の方が世界で一番頭が悪いかもしれません
で 生きる上で生命は苦楽
幸福 苦楽を感じるんだよとお釈迦様おっしゃっているんです
雨を舐めるとちょっとおいしく感じる
お医者さんからもらった薬の錠剤をベロの上に乗って舐めてみると
えらい気持ち悪くなっちゃうんです
だからさっさと飲み込まなくちゃいけないんです
だからそれって普通でしょうに
だからこの生きる上で楽を感じること
苦を感じること 幸福 苦楽を感じることとは違う話なんです
すべては無常なので 執着に値しないので
結局空しいのだと見なすべきという意味なんです
あ これ私のもの これ私は取ってやりますとかね
花見鼻さす持ちますとかね
下らんことをやるなよと
あなたは無常で変化するし
あんたにいじりしめたものも無常で変化するんだよと
だからこの価値がないんだと
変わるんだから 例えば花見が美しい
あれ持っていける あの瞬間だけ美しく見える
それで終わっちゃう 何もない
ただ気持ち悪い煙だけ
だからそんな風に見れば
そんな風に生きていれば
何も執着しないでいれば楽やっていうことで
この虚しいと すべて全体的に虚しいとは価値がない
私は無価値という言葉も使います
それがドッカの意味なんですよ
生きることは苦しい 苦しいっていうバカな話じゃないんです
そんなことを言うためには
お釈迦様はいらんでしょう
もう一つの単語 誤解している
スンニャ パーリ語でスンニャ
サンスクリット語になってくるとシューニャ
えーと 大乗仏教でもよく使う単語なんですね
空という それで知識人が
ああ 仏教はすべて空っぽだと言っているんだと
終わりだと言っているんだよと
冗談でしょ 虚無という意味ではなく
空っぽ 虚無という意味ではなく
相対性を超えたことを意味するための相対的な言葉です
だから仏教の空という単語すら相対的なんですね
だから相対性っていうのは
長い短いで比較してください
長いという単語に意味があるように感じちゃうでしょ？短いという単語に意味があるように感じるでしょ？短いと言ったらわかるでしょ？でもあなた
何がわかったんですかね
結局は短いと言ったら
ただ脳みその中で短いと言った途端
何か長いものを妄想して
それが比較しているんです
だから この相対的にあるように見える
実際 実際するように錯覚してしまう
それに空と言うんです
だったら本物はもう喋れない
本物には単語がないんです
だからそれにまた相対的な単語
空という単語を使って
単語はすべて相対的なんですよ
だから親鸞晩年の本来の姿は何なのかと言ったら言うと
単語がないんです 単語がないんだけど
何か言ってください 言ってください
まあ空想だと思ってくださいと言うんです
空であること 空所 空だけは使いません
空だけ使っちゃうと もう邪教なんですね
だから法華信願邪教なんです
で 空 空所と書いてないんです
はい 次に まあまだ単語ありますよ
みんなはちゃめちゃ間違ってる
単語はこんな全部言えません
だからやめる これでこの彩の彩の園というんだけど
本当は彩だけなんですね
彩の京 なんか分からないんだけど
伝統的にというか みんなもう彩の園
彩の園と言っているようになってますけど
まあ本当はあの彩なんです
彩の京   犀はあんまり群れを作りませんね
雌は子供と一緒にいるだけで
子供がいない場合は一人一人でいるんですね
人間嫌いで反社会的な生き方を謳っていると勘違いして大人気な経典です
特に日本で結構人気ですね
この犀の経典は中村先生
どんな馬鹿にも理解できるように日本訳しちゃったんだから
またすごい天才だから
結構いい日本語で難しいと全く感じさせないで
まあ中学生にでも読んで理解できるというふうに書いたので
これは先生が天才だからできたんで
読む馬鹿も天才やと思ったら困るんです
ね で 結構人気ある よく見ると
これ 反社会的なことを謳っているとみんな勘違いしているんです
この経典で だってずっとリフレインで栄光チャレカッガヴィサーナかっぽ
犀のごとく一人で住めなんです
どんな歌の最後のフレーズは
これリフレインですぐと出てくるんです
これで日本人がね 調和やらあれやこれや言ってるわりに
かなり中身が反社会的なんですね
だからこの経典 人気あるんです
だから親族は人嫌いですね
それはよくよくわかりますよ
私はスリランカ人だからね
やっぱり私たちがどこかに行こうと思ってバスに乗っちゃったら
もう 2 3 分でみんなとギャーギャーギャーしゃべるんです
全然こうやってじーっと固めていません
よ 仲良く喋って 降りたら降りて帰ってきます
あんまり運転手さんとしゃべれませんだけど
それでも運転手さんとしゃべる人がいるし
もうしゃべる しゃべる
だからそんなに人嫌いということはないとはないわけじゃないんだけど
それでもはっきり言うんだ
何々何性格の何々人がね
本当に悪いやつですねとかね
まあそうでね だなとかね
違いますよとか そういう喋ったりする
日本ではなかなかね お互いよく知らない限りは喋れないんですね
別にそれは現代時代だからね
まあ仕方がないこともありますが
やっぱりこの反社会的な精神っていうのはね
ちょっとまずいんですよ
この経典は勘違いしています
まず慈しみを謳っているのです
この犀の経典が まず慈しみを謳って始まるんです
サッベーすブーテーす二台ダンダン
という言葉で すべての生命に対して
いかなる武器も持つことをしないで
すべての生命のことを憐れんで生活しましょうと
それ言ってから経典が始まるんです
なのに それがポイする
慈しみが理解しない だから
これ 慈しみがある人の生き方なんです
わがまま張って人に迷惑をかけませんと
人のことを心配するんだと
すべての生命のこと そういう偉大なる経典なんです
で 恐ろしく勘違いしている
それでもう一つポイントがありますよ
これは決してお釈迦様が喋ったとは言ってないんです
あの大乗仏教の中にもこの経典が入っているんです
あまりにも古いんです
だから大乗仏教という経典にマハーヴァストゥというテキストがありまして
バカでかいテキストですけど
そちらにこの経典が入っているんです
そちらもこれは釈尊が悟ったと聞いた独覚ブッダたちが 100
人ぐらいいて それもブッダなんですよ
しかし 独覚人に喋れません
いわゆる空性だから喋る能力がないんです
自分らが空性に相対性超えている精神にいるんだから
そこをまたちょっと汚れた世界の足を踏んでみようということはできなくなったんです
できないんですね それのすごい放電能力が必要なんです
師匠としてる能力 人間みんな師匠にならないでしょ
勉強しても博士になってもね
いい教授になりませんよ
それはベースの能力 で
そこで小学者が現れたら
独覚ブッダは 帰るんです
涅槃に入るんです 一緒にいない
そこで一人一人涅槃に入っちゃったんです
涅槃に入る前に 最後に一芸だけでも教えましょうと
人類のために 一生一回の説法
一芸 四芸二行で それをまとめて犀の経典にしているんです
だからたくさんお経あったかも
たくさん芸があったかも
いくらかまとめて仏教の世界で
それを大事な教えだから暗記して持っているんだと
だからテーラワーダの場合でも
注釈紹介書く場合は これは独覚ブッダの教えであるとはっきりしています
だからお釈迦様が反社会主義者やというね
言うのはとんでもない話なんです
はい 一行一芸 一は慈しみを語る
芸 2番目を見てください
次の芸 サンサッガ ジャータッサ バヴァンテ スネーハ
スネーハン ワヤン スネーハン ワヤン
ドゥッカ ミダム パホーティ
アーディー ナワン スネーハ ジャム ペッカマーノ
エーコ チャレー カッガ ヴィサーナ カッポ
書いてますか？はい その芸を謳っているんです
意味は 交わって生きると愛着が起こる
愛着 執着は煩わしいと知って
犀のように孤独に生活する
そこで愛着が悪いと言っているだけなんです
だって我々も誰かと仲良くしていると
どんどん2日 3日になってくると
その人のことが気になってしょうがなくなっちゃうでしょ
あのショートメッセージでも送っている相手だったら
メッセージが来ないとあれどうなったの？というような
もう愛着が生まれてるんです
だからそこがこの交わることにある問題点だと
素晴らしいことを教えてるんですよ
だから愛着がない生き方が
一人で才能ごとく孤独で生きることなんです
次の芸はまあ次じゃない
いくつか言ったから サチェ ラベーカ ニパカン サハヤン サディン チャラン サーデュ ヴィハーリ ディーラン
アビドゥヤ サッバスサ サッバーニ パリッサヤーニ
チャライヤ エーテーナッタ マノー サティーマという芸があるんです
まあ共に生活できる友達としてね
友人として生活できる智者がいるならば
すべての束縛を捨てて
気づきを持ってその人と共に生きるべき
はっきりしています こちら犀のごとくと書いてないんです
この芸で もしあなたに立派な友達ができ
現れたら 理性のある友達が
頭のいい人があったら
すべて捨てて その人と友達になりなさい
ということは いかに良い友達を褒めているかということでしょ
すべて捨ててもいいんです
その場合は その人と一緒に生活するために
アッダパサンサーマサハヤサンペダンセッターサマ
これ 45番だけ セッターサマーセーヴィタブバーサハヤエーテーアラッダアナワッジェボージーエーコーチャレカッガヴィサーナカッポ
いきましょう 意味に自分より優れている
また自分と等しい付き合うすべき友人が確かに褒め称えよう
自分より優れた友達がいる
あるいは自分と性格的に同じ
その人を褒め称えましょうと
いわゆる友情を褒め称えているんです
この経典で もしそのような人がいなければ
だらしない 汚れている
悪に染まっている人々と仲良くして自己破壊するなよと
汚れて生き方をしないで
犀のように孤独 孤独 孤独で過ごす
これ反社会主義 すごい智慧の教えでしょ
次の日 バフスタンダンマダランバジェータミッタンウラーランパティバーナワンタンアンニャーヤアッターニヴィネーヤカンカンエーコーチャレカッガヴィサーナカッ
ポ
これは注釈しないとちょっと意味が取りにくいんだけどね
真理を学んでバフスタっていうのは
よく学問 学識があるって意味なんです
これ仏教の世界だから
やっぱり俗世間の学識よりはダンマを学んだことを言ってますけど
俗世間だったら学識のある人と友達になりなさいと
ダンマダランっていうのは学んだだけで意味がない
自分でもそれがこの自分のものにしていないと
それもよく理解してください
世界は勉強すればいいやと思ってるんですね
勉強すればいいはだけじゃないんです
勉強したものは自分のものにならないと
役に立たない だから世の中で人々は役に立っているのは
自分が学んだことは自分のものにしているんです
だからバフスタン ダンマダラン
両方必要なんです これ
仏教の用語かもしれませんだけど
バフスタンを俗世間に変えましょうか
バフスタン学識がある
ダンマダラ知識は自分のものにしている
体感している 使える 次の言葉は
そういう人々バジェート付き合いなさいよと
ミッタンウラーラン まあすごい立派な偉大なる友達やと
パティバーナワンタン
そこは私はひらめきがひらめきがある人と付き合うこと
このひらめきっていうのは
学識あっただけでではなくて
問題が起きたらすぐあ
この場合こうしましょうと
すぐ解決できる それは新たにひらめきなんですね
普通の人間にはこのひらめきが少ないんですよ
だから問題が起きちゃうと落ち込んじゃうんです
どうしよう どうしようと
ひらめきがあった ああそう
じゃあこうしますと すぐ答えが出てくるんです
それはブッダの教えを学んだっても同じことになるんです
学ぶ自分の仏教を学ぶ
自分のものにする 人が質問したら
自分に問題が起きたらすぐひらめきが現れるという 3
原則というか  3つの条件を揃えている人が素晴らしいんだから
絶対仲良くしなさいと
そういう人と 意義を知って疑がなくして
犀のように孤独に過ごす
その場合も犀のようにと書いているんです
だから そういう素晴らしい人と生活すると
仏教の場合は疑いがなくなるんです
俗世間では疑いがなくなりませんだけど
仏教の場合は生きる意味を理解する
いわゆる空しいであると
それから疑い 疑いがなくなる
すべて無常で因縁であるとわかったら
疑いがない その人の生活は孤独生活というんです
これも精神的なことを語っているんです
はい それでわかりますか？どれほど仏教のことを誤解されているのかと
次に友達友情論に入ります
これ友情論だから なんで友達がそんなに
なんで犀の経典すら あれほど派手に友達作れって言ってるんですかね
あれほど派手に 才能経典は人間と人間
人間 交わる 混じると執着
束縛 煩わしいことを生まれるんだから
超気をつけてくださいなんです
しかし 理性のある人とぴったしと一緒になって生活しなさいと
あの人間というのは変な生き物ですよ
人間というのは学ぶ生き物なんです
まあ他の動物もいろいろ学ぶんだけど
でも人間の学び狂いは並みじゃないんですね
人間がもう学び狂いな
学ぶは学ぶは学ぶは そういうふうにシステムできてます
その進化を説明する場合は
人間も猿だからね 90%以上チンパンジーとかね
ゴリラとゴリラとかね
遺伝子似ているんですけど
なんでこんなに違うのかと
学べるか学べないかなだけの差なんです
あのわずかな遺伝子で
わずかな遺伝子で学べる
学べないということは差がつけちゃったんです
学べることから 人間がすべての生命の邪魔な存在になってしまったんです
人間が他の生命を抑えて支配してしまっちゃったんです
だって学ぶんだから 知識
能力は天から降ってこないね
やっぱり学ばなくちゃいけないんです
ですからわかるでしょ？学ぶといえば
一人で学べる？教えてもらわないと
友情というそういうことな
人間関係なんです 知識
能力を本能として持って生まれない
生まれる赤ちゃんが超知識人とかね
ありえないんです どんな赤ちゃん生まれてもみんな同じなんです
何もできない 可能性だけ生まれる時ついてくるんです
いわゆる学べる可能性だけ持っているんです
だから この可能性には差がありますよ
だから知識の差も現れてくる
それから知識の主流も差も現れてくる
そこで知識で言っても
仏教は知識 能力全部まとめて考えているんです
能力が発達する可能性があるんです
赤ちゃんに ものを取れる可能性
赤ちゃんも最初はなんでもぎゅっと握っちゃうんですね
それだけ 赤ちゃんにおっぱいを吸ってる赤ちゃんに一切いかんのね
まあ指とかあげてみてください
指を握るんですよ なかなか取れないんです
なかなか取れない それだけしか能力ないんです
しかし やがて能力が上がっていくんです
学んで学んで学んで  人は他人から学ばなければならない
学んだ人はさらに観察して知識能力を発展します
一旦学んだら 自分がもう観察能力ついた人だけ
それは能力の世界 知識じゃない
知識とか能力を得た人に能力があれば
さらに観察する能力 その人は知識を増やしちゃうんです
そうやって人間社会が発展しているんです
いわゆるみんな発展と言いますけど
ダーウィンさんの言葉から見れば進化しているんです
進化か退化かはよくわかりませんだけど
とにかく仏教用語は変化している
だから人間進化するためには 100万年かかりますよとかね
嘘です 毎日進化しています
毎日 だから私は日本に来てすごく長いんだけど
もう信じられないくらい日本社会変わっちゃったんです
日本人が変わったんです
私だけ進化遅れて同じ場所にいるんだけど
みるみるうちに変わるんです
昔の人々は何百年も努力して得た知識能力は
現代人は 5  6 年で学んじゃうんです
学校で一年ぐらい授業を受けたらね
あの知識量は人間積み重ねるために何年かかったんですかね
数学学ぶときでも ささささっともうダラダラダラダラとやって終わってるんですよ
でも初めからかなり苦労しましたよ
先人たちは 昔の人々は
人間に学ぶことが呼吸と同様で欠かせない
だから学びたくないと人間が思うならば
資格を返してください
人間としての資格がちょっと問題です
学ぶことは どんな人間にも呼吸と同じく欠かせないものにしなくちゃいけないんですよ
だっていろいろ学ぶと
なんとなく心が活性化するでしょ？なんか生きがい感じるでしょ？じゃああれ学ぼう
これ学ぼう あれ調べようと思うと
なんとなく生きがいを感じるんです
だからそれを忘れてはならない
なぜなら 学ぶことから問題は起きてないんです
次のポイントは 心は影響を受けるんです
心って不思議なものなんですよ
心は環境に依存して活動する
我々の心っていうのは独立させますが
いつでも環境に依存するんです
育ててない心が ブッダだけ心を育てて
環境に依存しないようにしましょうと言ってますけど
現実離れの思考回転は病気です
そこで私たちの間でありますね
妄想しているんです すべてのすべて現実離れなんです
気をつけてください 妄想
とても危険です これは病気になるんです
精神的に病気になったら
もう人間も終わりです
精神病気ってなかなか治りにくいんですよ
なかなか かかったら だから常に心を環境に依存しておいた方がいい
例えば精神病の人はこう言う
私のことをみんな批判している
私のことをみんな恨んでいる
あるいは遠く二人が喋っていると
あの二人が私の悪口を言っているという病気があるでしょ
そうすると あなたに話が聞こえないでしょうにと
あなたに聞こえなくても
私に聞こえますよと えらい強なるくぶっちゃうんです
だからもう治らない病気にかかっているんです
だって この人がいるところで人は喋れなくなっちゃうんだから
あ こんにちはと確かに言ったっても
口先だけでこんにちはと言っても
私のことを恨んでいると思っちゃうんだから
だから現実離れ 環境に依存しないっていう
この病気 ブッダが教えてる環境に依存しないことではないんです
だから私たちが人が言っていることを聞こえなかったら
全然なんか喋ってる そういう風に環境に依存して考えてください
何言ってるの？知らん
知るわけないでしょうと
そういうふうに具体的な環境に依存していると
普通な常識な心で生きていられます
誰と一緒に生きるのか
誰を選んで誰を避ける
あ 一行抜けちゃったんですね
ですから 自分は将来何者になるかとは
自分と一緒に生活する人々によります
環境依存型だからね だから
どんな人間も将来どうなるのかということは
生きている環境で推測できます
ですから 誰と一緒に生きるのか
誰を選んで誰を避けるのかとは
幸福を目指す人間にとっては死活問題です
軽く見ないでください
我々の心は環境依存型です
だから自分で環境を選びなさいなんです
人を心配する善人は友情について
語るのです そういうわけで
人のことを心配する善人というのは
これ お釈迦様のことなんですね
でお釈迦様ではなくて
誰でも入るようにと単語を入れ替えたんです
善人は我々のことを心配しちゃって
友情について教えてくれるんです
大事な項目でしょうと
あなたの命と同じだよと
それで良心の問題 親は選べませんね
親との関係は独立までです
だから人間にとって親だけは選べませんだけど
本当はあれ嘘ですよ 生まれ変わるんだから
我々はどこかの生命だからね
その時誕生する生命が親を選ぶんです
業によって選ぶではなくて
座席は決めるんだ あんたこちらへと
空港でカウンターに自分のチケットをしたら
向こうはもうボーディングパスくれるでしょ
ボーディングパスに座席番号書いてますからね
これ変えられませんね
しかし そこで頭使ってね
前もってネットで航空券買って
それからネットにアクセスして
自分好みの座席を選んで決定することもできます
現代では 昔はできませんでしたけど
で でなきゃカウンターのお姉ちゃんが決めてくれるんです
はい そこは我々はあまりわかりません
だから 俗世間的に親は選べないということにしましょう
しかし 親との関係は永遠じゃなくて
独立するまで それから親孝行する義務があるだけです
育ててくれたんだから
親が死ぬまで親孝行しなくちゃなだけ
人間失格なんです そんな大げさなことじゃないんです
しかし 親に依存しない
覚えておいてください
独立したら親に依存しないこと
代わりに親孝行する 親孝行すると
親が自分に頼ることですよね
親は基本的なに必要なことを教える
親も先生で 親も友達で友人で
必要なことを教えてくれる
まあ仏教から見れば この良い人間で生きなさい程度でいいんです
嘘を言うなよ 人と喧嘩するなよと
仲良くしなさいよと 何かもらったものを友達と分けてあげてくださいよと
そういういい人間になりなさい
それだけ親の仕事は 日本の親はそれをやってない
知識は先生から学校で学びます
日本の親は良い人間で生きることを教えないで宿題を教えたてている
勘違いもいいところです
数学を教えてあげる 下手なくせに
余計なことするなよと
お母さんが数学の先生だったら教えてもいいんです
お母さんも習字のプロだったら習字を教えてもいいんです
自分の子供がサッカーやりたがったら
お母さんサッカーを教える
何考えてるんですかね
余計なことする必要はないんですよ
もしお父さんがサッカーの選手をやっていたならば
高校でも息子にいろいろ技を教えてもいいんですよ
でなきゃそれプロに任せちゃえばいいんです
だから学ぶことは学校でやるんです
できる人に任せるんです
親の責任じゃないんです
親には監督する義務があるんだから
塾に出したら学んでいるかないかチェックする
学んでないんだったら
お前明日から塾に行かせません
金は無駄と言ってもいいんです
家にいなさい バカで それ以上言うやる必要はないんですよ
本当に子育てってすごく楽なんですよ
良い人間になることだけ教えればいいんだから
友人と友人を自分でやる
次のまあ 学校で先生たちはもう結局は自分で選ぶ場合もありますからね
学校を選ぶとかね いろいろありますけど
やっぱり選んでいるんですよ
学校を選ぶ 親と一緒に学校を選ぶんだけど
みんな失敗するのは友人選びなんですね
その場合は親にも割り込むことができないんです
現実的に 子供は自分で友達を選ぶんです
この世でこの流れはうまく進まないようです
やっぱりこれは自然の流れですけど
あまりうまく流れないんですね
いろいろトラブルがあるんです
ガス管 水道管などに例えてみれば
管があちらこちらでひび割れが入っていて
これ危険でしょ 水漏れガス漏れするんだから
流れがスムーズに流れるんだったら
何の問題もないんです
はい 次 もう友情論語ってますよ
あの後で言いますけど
仏教では友人と先生っていうのは区別しないんです
区別しないんです その理由は後で説明します
で 今人間が成長したければ
まあ親から基本道徳ぐらい覚えておいて
社会にどう活動すればいいかというところね
覚えておいて それから学校で教えてもらって
友達からいろいろ経験を得て成長しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで問題が起こるんです
感情の障害 人は感情で友達を選ぶんです
そこはものすごい大きい問題です
感情は無知が作るんです
感情は無知の 何といいますか
プロダクションですよ
無知から生まれるんです
だからあの人のことを気に入っている
だから友達になろうとかね
やめなさいよと そっち感情が入っている
感情は無知です あの人はすごく可愛い
かっこいい じゃあ友達になってやると
ダメです でもみんなそうやってしまうんです
見た目で感情で人を選ぶ
結婚相手であっても 感情だけで選ぶと不幸になります
結婚相手っていうのは
感情は主であることは決まってますよ
でもそれ一つの条件にしてはいけません
この人とずっと生活しなきゃいけないんですよ
感情だけで 可愛いだけで
美人だけで 美人って 1
2年で終わりますからね
崩れますから ではなくて
別な理性で選んでほしい
性格は何なのか 好き嫌い何なのか
物事はどうやって見ているのか
世界に対してどんな考えを持っているのか
そういうところで合致するならば
そんなそれほど美人でなくても
ものすごく幸せになります
性格が合致するならば
見た目は全然関係なくなっちゃうんです
知識 能力 性格 人格 道徳などを参考にするべきです
仏教の話はすべて省略しました
知識 能力 性格 人格 それから道徳
どこまで道徳的ですかとか
そこら辺とても大事なポイントです
感情じゃないんです 人格的に優れている人を友人にするのだが
のだとはブッダのアドバイスです
お釈迦様は人格者とを友人にしなさいよ
1 行で終わっているんです
だから善友っていうのは人格者っていう意味なんです
そこで人間関係でいろいろ問題が起こるんですね
良い仲間に巡るあったにしましょう
いい仲間に巡り合いました
その過程で 互いに感情で結ばれるようになります
それから感情でも結ばれるんですね
愛着が生まれると 自我が割り込むので
自分のことを優先に考えてしまいます
自分の付き合い 性格が合っている
気に入っている相手に感情が出てくると
自分がわがままになってわがを言い張っちゃうんです
自分のこと優先になってしまいます
結婚したらどうしてなるでしょ
旦那が自分のことを優先にしてしゃべる
奥さんが自分のことを優先にしてしゃべる
そこでもう 死ぬまで結婚する
喧嘩するんです 夫婦喧嘩は新鮮だと勘違いしているでしょ
仏教的な夫婦は喧嘩しませんよ
なぜならば自分を優先にしないんです
友人にとって迷惑になります
自分わがままを言うと
たとえ友達であっても
お前本当に迷惑だなと言って
どんどんどんどん引いてしまいますよ
希望通りにならない ならないようと怒り
憎しみなども起きます
そこで人間関係うまくいかない
希望通りに希望通りいくわけないでしょうよ
なんで人間希望通りにいきたがってるんですかね
なんで希望を作ったんですかね
自我でしょ？わがままでしょ
友達一人がいるならば
お互いの考えを話し合って
何かのコンプロマイズにならなくちゃいけないでしょ
だからコンプロマイズなんです
生き方は みんなコンプロ
コンプロマイズ 何でしたっけ？妥協
妥協は嫌がるんですね
なぜ妥協は嫌がるのかというと
自分の気持ちが却下されるということで
その通りで通じないから仕方がないでしょ
妥協することが正しいと思ったならば
別に簡単に友達を作れます
はい 次 人間関係の問題
親子 家族 親族 友人 仲間などの関係があります
それも人間関係ですね
愛着 嫉妬 競争心 自我などが割り込むと関係が崩れます
なんで家族関係崩れるんですか？愛着
憎しみ割り込んでくるんだから
なんで親と子の関係が崩れるんですか？親の愛着なんです
兄弟もお互い嫉妬しちゃうと
お互い競争心現れてくると派手に喧嘩するんです
敵同士になるんです 我が子であっても心配
慈しみは良いのですが
愛着が現れると互いに喧嘩することになります
我が子だったら心配しなさい
慈しみなさい それで終わりです
愛着作るなよ 我が子は敵になるんだよ
のこのこで自分を産んだ
産んで育てた子供を自分の敵に育てるんです
愛着を持って 決して愛着を持ってはいけないんです
感情は無知 無知から発生するので危険です
じゃあ愛着はなんで悪いかということも説明しましょう
私は誰かに愛着あるとは
その人の人権を侵害したことなんです
猫を飼ってるでしょ？犬飼ってるでしょ
我々は飼っちゃうと あの犬の
あの猫の人権侵害しているんです
自由がなくなっているんです
犬も猫も野生でいた方が本当に自由でしょ
愛着を持って飼った時点で向こうの人権が侵害されています
同時に自分の人権も 今日も朝道路を見たら
みんなもう寒いのにいっぱい色付くと犬たちを 3匹連れて 2
匹連れて  1匹連れて散歩に行くんですね
寒くて だから犬の散歩だから自分が散歩したことにもそれほどならないし
犬がガチャガチャ走りませんだからね
いろんなところ止まりますから
結局は人の生命の人権侵害しようとしたところで
自分の侵害 人権も侵害されているんです
愛着は良くないのはそういうわけなんです
我が子に愛着あるとは
我が人の人権を侵害することです
それ親がやるべきこと？親でやるべきことは
とことん心配してあげること
それだけです 人間関係で理性と慈しみがあるならば安全です
それであの鉄則それなんです
人間関係で理性で人間関係を作る
それから慈しみを忘れないように実践する
何一つ問題起きません
それから友情という単語にちょっと一言辛口言います
情は悪ですよ 感情の情だからね
友情という単語はおかしいんです
これ英語で言えばフレンドシップなんですね
友情じゃないんです 友人で在ることなんですね
また あまり使わない仏教用語ではフレンドリネスという仏教を英訳するとフレンドシップと書かないんです
我々はフレンドリネスと書くんです
で そうすると この連中の英語はちょっとかっこ悪いと思われるかもしれませんけど
意図的にこの単語を変えてフレンドリネスと書くんです
なぜならば フレンドシップよりはフレンドリネスの方がより美しいんです
より広いんです 友人であるという気持ちが大事なので
感情的に感じる恐れがあるので
仏教は友情は慈悲喜捨の仲間に入れます
だから友情 友情と言っちゃうと
なんか感情が割り込むんですね
だから仏教は慈悲喜捨という感情の
あの 何といいますか 完全清らかな場所に入れ替えるんです
だから友達は慈悲喜捨で作るんです
可愛いから友達にならない
醜いからといって差別して人を敵に回せない
慈悲喜捨で友達を作るんです
一般的にメッタメッタは友情と訳できますね
フレンドリネスなんです
フレンドシップではないんです
フレンドリネス 友情ですが
条件と場合によって友人に対してカルマムディタウペッカーも抱かなくてはならないんです
だから自分に友達がいるならば
基本的にはフレンドリネスで仲良しでいる
しかし 友達がちょっと困っちゃってる
悩んでる場合はカルナで
いわゆる心配する気持ちで対応する
友達がうまくいっている場合は
喜で ああ よかったあんたはと手をたたいて握手して
ムディタで対応する  何のことなく
それはそれで生活している
私は私は生活している状態になってくると
友達関係ヒットワイキキじゃないんで
その場合はウペッカーでシャーで関係を持つ
だから自分に友達がいるならば
その友達に対していつでも慈悲喜捨という感情
感情と言うしかないんだけど
あの感情を使ってください
普通の感情は絶対ダメだ
猛毒です 慈悲喜捨は理性から生まれるんです
無知から生まれません
はい それではね シャッター割りまして
基本的なところで で 結構今日スライドがたくさんあります
疲れたら言ってください
休憩入れます 師弟関係ではないのと
それで仏教では学ぶものだと言ってるでしょ
学ぶんだったら先生から学ぶでしょう
仏教は全然師弟関係は言ってない
あの戒律本には師弟関係書いてますよ
でもブッダっておかしいんですよ
師弟関係の場合は 師匠っていうのは親にしなさいと
親って 10人がいない 10
人いないでしょう 我々出家する場合も
あの二人ですよ アーチャリーウパッジャヤという
師匠 ウパッジャヤは出家を認めて出て行きますから
アーチャリアという師匠のところで育てます
師匠はもう何のことなく親親代わりにする
だからそれだけで学べる
自分の師匠があんまり勉強していない師匠だったらどうする？しかし
我々出家の中で師匠はまあ親になって面倒を見てくれますよ
心配してくれるわ 何かなくなる必要だったら
何か探してあげるわ 病気になったら一生懸命看病するわ
もう夜こそこそと隠れて寝ないで遊んでいるとものすごく怒鳴るわ
朝起きないでうろうろしていると
ものすごく怒鳴って蹴って起こすわけ
そうやって親の仕事をしているんです
だから我々の場合は 師匠っていうのは親以外何でもないんです
だから師匠が衰えてくると
ものすごく親孝行する
何でもやる だから出家の場合は
寝たきりになったっても
弟子がいれば全然問題ないんです
弟子たちがもうプロの看護婦さんたちにはかなわない
全部ちゃんと面倒見てあげる
それからすごい心掃除しているんだから
何のこともない ですから
仏教はあまり師弟関係について語っていないんです
だから我々の戒律で教えているのは
師匠に対してどんな態度対応するべきかと
それで至って簡単に親だと思いなさいよと
それから親に対するあれをだらだらと羅列しているんです
仏教師弟関係 社会的に師匠
弟子 先輩 後輩 上司 部下
親子 見習いと一人前などの上下関係があります
これ社会の問題 仏教の問題じゃないんです
社会ではいつでも上下関係
縦の関係 しかし これは真面目に上下だと思うと相手を見下すことになります
社会は縦の関係だと真面目に思っちゃうと
我々は上にいる連中が下にいる連中をバカにする
見下す それで下にいる連中はとにかく上の層を壊そうとする
エゴを張る結果になります
関係が崩れます よく会社で問題あるでしょ？上司が態度でかいとか
上司に怒られるとかね
上司は何も理解しない
あれやこれやとかね それで上司の人も私に言われたことあるんだけど
部下がいるんだけど 全然やる気がないとか
わがままやとかね あれは縦の関係に気づいているから
そういう問題を受けているんです
平等であること 皆に人権があること
簡単に無視するが 変えることはできない法則です
人間がアホですよ 社会は縦の関係じゃないんです
縦の関係を作れません
だって天皇陛下すらも国民に喋る場合は敬語で喋っているでしょうに
なんで私たちはそこから何か学べない
国民に対して敬語を使っているんです
だから縦の関係ないんですよ
だから一番日本的に文化的に無難なのは
相手に対してあまり気にしないで
敬語的に気持ちで喋ることなんです
子供やら小さな連中にはね
まあまあ切り捨てて呼んでもいいんだけど
その時でももうお前本当にハチャメチャ可愛いという感じを出して
それからバカにしたっても構いません
だからこれは人間の問題ですよ
縦の関係 だから社会の師弟関係
縦なんです 覚醒のみ上の存在です
生命の中で縦上にいるといえば悟った人だけなんです
もう離れているんです
俗世間から精神的に だから悟った方々はもう目上の方々だと尊敬に値する方々よと頭を下げてもいいんだけど
他は別に 仏教では師匠イコール友情なんです
師匠イコール専有なんです
釈尊はこの上のない師匠でもありながら
人類にとって本物の専有でもあります
釈尊が師匠でありならばありながら専有です
煩悩と無明で病んでいる生命に感知する治療を施すので
偉大なる医者とも言います
この単語を 3つお釈迦様は自分で使っているんです
だから医者上じゃないでしょ
医者は患者さんに治療するんだけど
医者が患者さんを見下す
その権利ないんです そこでパーリ語でアヌットロプルサダンマサーラティーと言うんですね
それはまあ 上京なんとか上部というね
上京上部でしたって どんな人も育てることはできるんだと
サッターデーヴァマヌッサーナ
神々人間の師匠であると
それからサッラーカットアヌットル
偉大なる医者であると
お釈迦様は自分のことを言うんです
俺は神様だ お前より偉いのだ
それはいけないんです
いつでも平等という言葉で語っているんです
それから優良師匠について勉強します
優良師匠 それも専業なんですけど
知識技術などを教えることはほとんど有料ですね
でも教える先生は 先生でしょ
学んだ人も自分が得た能力で生計を立てます
知識 能力 技術 能力は年とともに減ります
有料で学んだんだけど
学んだものは年とともに減ります
時代によって不必要にもなります
いろんな能力は今使えませんということになります
抜群な知識能力があっても
悪人なら人間関係を築けないならば
社会から却下されます
いくら有料で世界一の先生のところで学んでも
天才的な能力を発揮して知識になっても
性格が悪ければ追い出されます
そこで有料師匠はこんな程度なんです
学費を払わなくちゃいけないでしょ
次に無料師匠という専業です
だから師匠＝専業 善悪を教える人
正しい生き方を教える人
性格を改良する方法を教える人
強いて言えば 良い人間になる方法を教える人は無料です
授業料はないんです 仏教に限った現象ではありません
仏教だけではなくて 世の中一般的ですよ
世間一般的です 面白いでしょうね
良い人間になることを教える先生がいたら
授業料を払わないんです
どこでも 例えば神父さんのところでも行ってね
いろいろ生活にいろいろ問題があって
相談に乗ってみてください
無料です 喜んで教えてあげる
間違ったことを教えるかもしれませんだけど
本人が真剣だからね  ある日
日本で私が得た経験なんですけど
このちっちゃな子供を連れてどこかに遊びに行ってね
そこでみんなこの まああの
何といいますか 新幹線の模型運転なんですね
だからこのモニター画面で動くだけでね
自分でちょっと操縦すればいいんです
それでみんなやりたいんだから
ちっちゃな子供たちが並んでるんですね
そこで子供を連れて大人もいるんですね
私も子供 ちっちゃな子供一人連れて行ったんだから
私も並んでいる 私は別にあれやらなかったんですけど
そこでちょっとやんちゃな中学生程度の子供たち何人かいで
はっちゃめちゃふざけて遊んでるんですね
あちらからここっていうのは
ここから来るわ お互い喧嘩するわ
また走り回るわ もう列を破ってあちら行ったり
もう面倒くさいんですね
でも私はまあ別に 並んで待ってるのはやんちゃな子供たちには苦痛だからふざけただけだと思いますけど
そちらで体格のある男がいたんですね
ものすごく怒鳴ったんですね
何やってるの？しっかりおとなしく並んでいなさいと
なんだ 列を破ったり潜ったり行くんだ
性格悪いよと で がくんと怒鳴っちゃったんですね
怒鳴った途端 怒鳴られた途端
子供たちがびっくりしちゃって
丁寧に並んでるんですね
それでその人が あ それでいいよと
またちょっと褒めてあげて
だからその人が行儀さを教えたでしょ
これ無料でしょ お前に行儀さを教えるんだから
円くださいと言ったら誰が払う？だから自然法則的に道徳を教えることは無料になっているんです
有料で道徳 正しい生き方などを教える人に慈しみが欠けているんです
有料で教える宗教組織もありますよ
行かないでください あれはもうインチキだと思いますね
だから真理は無料で教えなくちゃいけないんです
専業にならない 有料だったら
その場合は知識 有料で教える先生は専業になります
学校の先生は専業です
給料もらってますけど
道徳 生き方 良い人間になることを有料で教える人があまり専有にならないんです
良い人であること 人格者であることは
生涯も死後も役に立ちます
この無料で教えてもらうことは生涯役に立ちます
有料で教えてもらうことは
わずかな時間で無効になっちゃうんです
これをよく理解してください
死後も良いところに行くのは良い人間だけなんです
しかし教えは無料 えーと
どうしますか？今何時間喋ったっけ？ん？じゃあ皆様疲れているんだから
ちょっと休憩しましょう
はい ではご案内であります
本題に入りますね 仏道と専有ということ
で 専有に出会い出会えば
人は解脱に達する だからいい友達がいれば幸せになるということは楽しくなるのは当たり前ですけど
お釈迦様は友達さえいれば解脱にまで人は成長するんだと言っているんですね
ということは 人は学ぶ生き物なんですよ
学ぶ場合は師匠が必要なんですね
仏教は師匠と言わない
専有と言うんです だって自分を育てるんだから
縦の関係ないんだからね
生命の中で だから専有から解脱に達するまで自分を育てることはできますよと
はい 専有の意味 自分のことを心配する
良いアドバイスをする
助けになる人は世間的な専有です
だからまあ心配している人がいれば専有です
でも心配している人がいるからといって
その人のおかげで悟るということはありえないんです
心を清らかにする方法
智慧を開発する方法 煩悩を断つ方法を教えて導く人は仏道の専有です
それは一般人にはできない
だから仏道の専有です
ダンマを学んで理解して教えてくれる人々は専有になります
ですから ダンマというのはブッダの教えですね
誰かがよく学んで理解して教えてくれるならば
その人のことを専有だとした方がよろしいんですね
釈尊は専有本物です 釈尊は誰の専有にもなります
専有と仏道 サカラメーワミダンアーナンダブラフマチャリヤンガリダンカルヤナミタタカルヤナサハイタカルヤナサンパワンカタ
アーナンダよ 専有がいること
善友と伴うこと 善友に傾くことが仏道のすべてなのです
すべて善人にかかっています
次の経典  カルヤナミッタセータンアーナンダビックーノパーティカンカンカルヤナサハサハヤッサカルヤナサンパワンカッサ
アリアンアッタンギカンマッガンバハヴィーセティアリアンアッタンギカンマッガンバウリーカリセティ
長い文章ですけど 直訳すると
善友がいるならば 善友と一緒に生活するならば
善友の話に耳を傾ける人に限って
八正道を実践して完成することは可能ですと
他の人にできません 八正道を完成したということは
悟りに達したということなんですね
だからこれって一つの授業のようなことで
一回授業を受けたではなくて
その授業を全部順番で受けて実習していかなくちゃいけない
だからやっぱり師匠がずっとついていなくちゃいけない
それで師匠ではなくて
この場合は善友ですね
ママ
ンヒサーリプッタカルヤナミッタアーガマジャーティダンマサッタージャージャーティヤパリムッチャンティジャラーダンマサッタージャラーヤパリムッチャンティマラナ
ダンマサッターマラナーナパリムッチャンティソーカパリデーワドゥッカドーマナサウパーヤスダンマサッターソーカパリデーワドゥッカドーマナサウパーヤスヒパリムッチャンティという
お経です
経典です 善友である私に出会って
生まれること 性質のある生ですね
生命が生から解放される
老いる性質の生命は老いることから解放される
死性質を生老病死ですね
全部書いてます  病は入れてないんだけど
で 死ぬ運命になっている生命が
死という現象から解放される
憂い 悲しみ 嘆き 悲しみ
悩み あらゆるものに 落ち落ちる性質の生命が
老いから悲しみから 死から憂いから解放されますよと
それで私のように善友に出会ってって言うんです
私って誰？お釈迦様なんですね
だからサーリプッタ尊者に言うんです
この場合は 善友とはブッダのことであると
あのキリスト教みたいに神の我は神の子であるとは言わないんです
我は特別存在であると
特権だと イスラム教でもモハメッドという人が偉い人なんですね
で 再掲のこれで終わりです
あの  善友の話はだいたいそういうところで
友情論が終わります それからちょっと皆様に実践的に必要なところを説明しますが
これは本も書いてありますから
あんまり詳しくなくてもいいんです
善友かぶり 要するに悪友
世の中で皆様には善友かぶりが結構いるんですよ
善友のように見えるんだけど
かぶっているんですね
これは見に見抜いた方がよろしいのです
善友かぶり一 この一にはアンニャダットハローアミットと言うんです
持ち逃げ屋なんです 持ち逃げ悪友
で ちょっとユーモア的な言葉を使ってますが
まあ持って帰る とにかく何かを持って帰る
そのためにえらいまあ
褒めるわ いろいろからくりあるんですね
最後に何か持って帰るんです
自分のもの その人を発見する方法あります
4つあります 何かもらうために付き合う
電話かけてきたら何か要求があるんです
家を訪ねたら何か要求があります
たまに出かけましょう
呼ばれたら何か最後に実はこれ何かくれませんか？と言うんですね
わずかなことをしてあげて
たくさんのことを期待する
自分もちょこちょこと何かくれたりするんですけど
それすごいいろんなもの
期待するんですね  1,200円のお菓子のお土産持ってきて
あのまあ10万円も金貸してくれないのかというような話なんです
自分に危険がある時のみ付き合う
自分に何か問題がある時
自分が悩んでいる時 自分が困っている時だけ
だって友達でしょ？助けてよと言うんですね
自分が調子がいい時はとはないんです
自分の利益だけ求めて付き合う
だから 皆様の友達の中でも
相手がいつでも何か利益を取るだけで
自分には何もない 自分があげるだけで
自分から持っていくだけの友達かぶりがいるんです
それは仏教はアミットと言うんです
友人ではありません と
はい 悪友 2番目 ワチーパラマアミット
ワチーパラモアミット
口先だけの悪友 口先だけ
発見する方法は 4つあります
一 過去形で接待する 先週あんた来たならば助けてあげたのに
と言うんですね そんな程度じゃないないよ
もうもっともっといろいろなことをしてあげあげたあげられたのにと
先週だったら 未来形で接待する
もっと彼のことじゃなくて
例えば  自分の誰かが病院にいる
自分にはもうちょっと病院に行けなくなっちゃった
しかし 何かいろいろ食べるものやら
いろんな必要なものをちょっと病院に持っていってあげなくちゃいけない
だからよく一緒に生活する友達がいる
友達に私は今日本当に病院に行けないんだから
これお願いできる？そしたら今日はまずい
もう明日なら暇があるんだけどと
って言うんです 明日は自分も休みだからね
行けます 病院に そうやって将来未来形で接待する
役に立たないことで接待する
自分にいろいろなものをやってくれますけど
一つも役に立たない だから相手の相手の役に立つ形でどうでもなくて
何か何かやってあげて
4番目 現在の問題に対して却下する
できませんとはっきり言う
これはちょっと無理ですよと
問題が起きたら友達に
これはもうどうしようもないと却下するんです
これは 2番目の悪友 はい
3番目の悪友 機嫌取る
あのピーバーに口合わせるんですね
発見する方法は 4つあります
悪を犯すと賛成する 自分がいろんな悪いことを言うと
まあいいですよ 別にね
そんなことやったからといってどうったことないでしょとかね
結構賛成してくれるんです
善を行うとき賛成する
自分が良いことを言うと
ああ それはそれ すごくいいことですよとかね
まあ例えば友達がね 私は老人ホームに行ってちょっとボランティアしたいと思っていますけどと
とてもいいことですね
素晴らしいですね まあどうぞどうぞやってくださいと賛成してくれる
私はあの店の店員 店員さんとね
すごく腹が立っているんだから
何か万引きしてやろうと思ってるの
あいつに 損害与えて それだったらいいでしょう
やってください そんな調子が悪いんだったらね
店員さんが それも賛成する
それで口を合わせるんですね
出会った時は褒めてあげる
会ったらもうね あんた会いたくて
本当にあんたみたいな人間に会うことは
なんで私は幸せですか？とかね
褒めるんです 目の前で
目の前で褒める いない時は批判する
いない時はもうバカにする
それは口先だけの機嫌取りの悪行ですね
はい  4種類ですよ だから発見する方法もお釈迦様は 4つ
4つにまとめたんです
これは在家の若者に教えたんです
だから覚えやすく数字さえ揃っているんです
で 堕落への案内人 4番目の友達はアパーヤサハヨアミットというんですね 1
酒 麻薬などを使用するとき付き合う
本人が一人でなんかやる自信がなくてね
あ いいよいいよ 付き合ってあげますからと
酒飲んだり まあ日本人には飲み友達はいっぱいいるんですけどね
2番目 夜遊びなら共にする
夜遊びっていうのは このインドの文化ではね
あの まあ日本でも夜遊びはいいことではないんだけど
やっぱり電気はない時代だから
夜はもう暗いでしょうに
だから夜っていうのは犯罪者と泥棒たちの時代
時間なんです そこで一般人があちらうろうろしていて
そこでどこかで泥棒でも起きたら
この人を捕まってしまうんですね
だから出かけてはいけないときは出かけてはいけないんですよ
昔の話で 今も夜遊びはやめた方がいいんですね
夜遊びしたいんだったら
友達はすぐ付き合ってくれます
そこで例えば自分が夜遊びに行きたい
それで自分の家族が崩れてしまう
友達はそれ言ってくれない
そんなことあんた家族がいるでしょうに
子供いるでしょうに そんなことやめたらどうと
それは言わない あ いいよいいよ
一人で行けないんだけど
私も一緒に行きますと
3 社会が求めないクラブ活動などで一緒になる
これ あのサマージャ サマージャなんとかサマッジャッターなんとかという
いろいろあのクラブあるんですね
踊りクラブとかね 昔はディスコクラブとかあったんですね
それで裸で踊るね もうそういうクラブもあるし
いろいろ汚いものはあるんですよ
結局 結局はみんな一人で行くのは勇気がないんですね
いろんな日本でもね 結構繁栄しているしね
そういう違法的なクラブとかはね
店とかはね だからいて一人でノコノコと行って入るっていうことはちょっと難しい
で 誰か一緒に連れて行くんですね
そういうものを付き合ってくれる友達
この 4種類の戦友かぶりを危険であると知って
直ちに縁を切るのです
お釈迦様には直ちに縁を切ってくださいと
友達関係 まあ知り合いでいいんで
まあこんにちは程度でね
友人にするなよと だって世の中で知ってる人はいくらでもいるでしょ
みんな友達じゃないでしょ
アーラカーパーリワジーというのは
もうものすごい もう却下しなさいと
マッガンパティバヤンやった
とても危険であると思った
はい それで戦友かぶりの悪人が 4種類います
気をつけなくちゃいけない
本物の戦友もいます また 4種類です
1 ミットスハジュ心底友人
ミットスハッスハドゥ
スハダッハダっていうのは心臓ですよ
心から友達っていう意味なんです
放逸になった時 いわゆる我を忘れた時
守ってあげる 人間っていうのは時々ありますね
自分が何やってるのかわからん
わからん わからなくなっちゃって
変なことをやったりする
突然怒ってしまって 人を殴ってやろうと思ったりもする
そうやって我を忘れる瞬間で
友達が守る 何をするのか？やめなさいと
まあまあ まあまあ いいでしょう
いいでしょうとかね 悪いことをさせないんですね
落ち着け 落ち着けとかね
あるいは今殴るって？今今殴らなくていいんですよ
明日計画立てて殴りましょうと何とか言って
その場を危険を冒さないようにその人を守ってあげる
不放逸になった時 財産を守ってあげる
だから例えば不放逸っていうのは酔っ払ったとしましょう
自分が酔っ払って調子に乗って服を脱がして捨てたり
もうあれやこれやとかやっていると
その人はこの人持っているね
財布やらいろいろ身分証明書
大事なものをなんとか取って
自分でちゃんと守って
どうぞどうぞ勝手にふざけてくださいと
してあげて それからもうあなたの財布ですよ
あなたの身分証明書でしょ
あなたの会社の入るこれアイデンティティカードでしょ
とか言って 後で 財産を守ってあげる
例えば大きく考えても
例えばもう戦争が起きて
自分が軍隊に入らなくちゃいけない
それでハチャメチャ戦争があったりして
だからこの人の自分の家族を守ることはできません
しかし 戦友がいるんですね
この戦友がいて この人の土地をちゃんと守ってあげて
田んぼを作る時期になったら
まあいいや もう作ってあげますとかね
そこも作ってあげて そうすると家族がそこでご飯を食べて生活
向こうは戦争に行って戦って
気楽に家に帰ると 家は大丈夫です
財産は守られている 友達がちゃんと守ってくれたんです
ということなんですね
困った時 いわゆる恐怖に陥った時
頼りになる 心配でたまらなくなったら
まあ大丈夫 大丈夫と それは何とかしてあげますよとかね
怖くなった時 心配に陥った時はさっさと調子はどうですか？まあそんな心配するなよとかね
日本でもね 例えば地震が起きて家が破れたり
避難しなくちゃいけないとか
そういう困ることは起こるでしょうね
友達がいたらさっと行ってな
してあげて 慰めてあげて応援するんですね
用事が現れたら必要以上に財産をあげる
これ昔のこと 今は必ず財産をあげなくてもいいんですけど
何か用事が起きちゃうと
例えば友達がしっかりと会社経営したいと思っている
しかし 資金足らない  100万ぐらいね
会社はうまくいったら結構収入が入る 100
万足らない いいや もう 200万出しますからね
しっかり頑張ってくださいと
と友達がいれば助けてくれるような感じなんですね
だから自分には何か用事があったら問題なくやってくれる
それは第1の戦友ですね
第2の本物の戦友 名前はサマーヌソクドゥッコミット
苦楽を伴う人 自分の秘密を告げる
友達が まあ人間いろいろだからね
人にバレたら困るものでも友達には言う
相手の秘密を守る 困った時は離れません
友達が困っていると この人はもう全然離れません
友人のために命さえ惜しまない
そういう友達が世の中でいるんですよ
で  3番目 本物の友達  3
名前はアタッカーイなんですね
導く戦友 苦楽を共にするじゃなくて導く
悪をやらせない 悪いことをやる
これは何やってるのかと
やめなさいとかね かなり叱る
善行をやらせる 逆に無理やりでも引っ張って良いことをさせる
ちょっと皆様にとってみたら
きつい友達なんですが
知らないことを教えてあげる
自分が知らないこと いろんなこと
あんた知ってるの？これはこういうこと
こういうことだとかね
だいたいこのケースの場合は
だいたい歳も上で 知識も自分より上の友達になるんですね
先生たちみたいなね  4番目
死後天界に生まれる方法を教える
だから仏教のお坊さんたちが
この 3番目の友達の仕事をしているんです
だって テーラワーダ世界では
この在家の方々はお坊さんたちとぴったし仲良くしているの
そういうわけなんです
友達なんです だけど もちろん喧嘩もしますよ
喧嘩してだっても お寺から出ていて
お寺にお寺破壊する それはないんです
しかし 我々出家としてもかなり厳しく言うんですね
何やってるのかと なんでちょんちょんな怒ったり怒鳴ったりする
だから なんでテーラワーダ仏教の世界はそんなにもう 2000年
2000年も経ってますからね
衰退していないんですね
仏教世界は 仏教関係のところは社会は衰退するかもしれませんだけど
例は出家はいつでもこの専業の仕事をやっているんです
だから死後天界にこんなことやったら
あんた地獄に落ちるんだからやめなさいという態度をとっているんですね
はい 最後 4番目の友達
アヌカンパコミット で心配する友達
友人が不幸になると悩む
心配する  あの人は今頃ね
商売もう行ってないしね
まあ奥さんもちょっと病気になって倒れちゃってね
心配するんですね 友達が幸福になると喜ぶ
あいつはね 今は順調で
仕事もね 結構評判繁盛してよかったねとかね
子供も東大に入っちゃって
なんてすごいことやと
なんか自分のように喜んじゃうんですね
他人が友人の非難するとやめさせる
何言うのかと あんたが間違ってる
そんな人間じゃないんだよと
いい人だと 私の友達から悪口を言うなよと
で やめさせるんです 他人が友人を褒めると
その人を褒めてあげる
賛成して そうですよ そうでしょ？私の友達ですからね
すごいいい人やと なんともすごく頭がいいですねとか
相手をどんどん褒めてあげるんですね
そういうふうに友達のことをものすごく心配するんですね
自分のもののように 自分と同様に
ということで 友人とは自と他がない人間関係なんですよ
我々は本当にこの先生の影響よりも
だって先生という概念があるでしょ？お母さんお父さんという概念があるでしょ
だからそういう概念があるんだから
ちょっと影響を受けるとフィルターを入れるんですよ
自分フィルターを入れて
自分自分好きな影響しか受けません
親からの 先生から友達の場合はフィルター使いませんね
そのまま影響を受けるんです
だから友人関係ってものすごい大事な関係なんです
だからお釈迦様はブッダのことを友人にしなさいと
だから我々はフィルターをつけないで影響を受ける人間を選ばなくちゃいけないんですね
皆様は俗世間的な場合でも
友達の場合はで 何も恥ずかしくも何ともなく
もう気楽に敬語を使わなくちゃとかそんなこともなく
すごい気楽に生活するでしょ
フィルターが入ってないんですよ
例えばこちらで皆様は私と喋る場合は必ずフィルターが入っちゃうんですね
だから友達っていうのはすごいありがたいことなんですよ
リラックスして気楽に生活できる環境だったら
素晴らしい人を選ばなくちゃいかないんです
そこで皆様は今 戦友を教えたでしょ？私たちのそういう友達が欲しいと思っちゃうでしょうかね
かぶりの方がいい かぶりの方がいくらでもいますからね
皆様が戦友を期待するならば
まず自分が戦友になることです
秘訣はいたって簡単 自分が人に対して戦友になる
そうすると簡単にいくらでも戦友を見つかるんです
たって簡単単純ですよ
視察問題じゃないんです
人を選ぶことは視察問題ですけど
やり方って簡単 自分が 4種類のあの 3番目はちょっと気をつけてください
それでも自分張らなきゃできますよ
友達は上じゃないんだからね
悪いことやめましょうよ
そんなこともう もう本当に悪いんだからね
いやいや 俺はとかね じゃあ出てきます
という感じで 対等で言うと
悪いことをやめさせることを良いことをさせることできます
戦友だから対等だから
だから自分に戦友が欲しいと思うならば
まず自分が 自分の能力範囲で
この４種類の戦友の中の一人になってください
ダブったってもいいんです
1番目の戦友の半分と
2番目の戦友の半分とかダブっちゃってもいいんだけど
どうったことはないんです
自分が性格変わると至って簡単に周りがいるんですよ
戦友が だから戦友って不思議な存在で
自分が発する波長が同じもの返ってくるんです
はい 終了します 友情その結論
結論は下書いてあります
他人の助けがなければ生きられない
共存の法則は欠かせない
人間にとって 自分の幸不幸は友人次第です
どうにもならん これは
共に生きる人間次第です
はい 話は以上でございます
で えっと 最近 あの瞑想とか
自分の感情に感情のままに流されることではなくて
その感情を見る いわゆる瞑想というものに
えっとを普段からしようというふうに心がけているのですが
あの 自分があの何か立ち仕事をしている時
あの体が痛かったり その心がだるかったりする
そのマイナスの感情を見続ける
観察し続けるということがすごく自分にとっては難しくて
それをする その その時にその感情に負けてしまって
見るということが冷静にできなくなることが多いんですが
何かアドバイスをいただければと思います
この世の中で当然当たり前のことしか何も起こりませんでしょ
だからこれ マイナスネガティブと思ったところで
ちょっと問題自分で判断しているんですね
立ってると体が痛くてだるくなるのは当然なことでしょ
これ マイナスでもネガティブでもないんです
だからニコニコとあー痛いなとかね
痛くなってる だるくなってるんだとか
そういう風に見てください
判断しないでください
ネガティブとか言えませんよ
世の中 ネガティブでもポジティブでもないんです
当然の流れなんです 頭がでっかちで判断しようとする
そちらに間違いあるんですね
だから見るだけで十分です
だから嫌だなと思ったら
それって当然でしょ 誰だってだるくなって欲しくないしね
まあ肉体的には苦痛でしょうしね
そういうことやそういうことだっていう風に感じて観察してください
ありがとうございます
じゃあ質問なかったら人生相談でも別にどうでもいいんです
最初の方で慈しみの気持ちは OK だけど
愛着はダメっていうことと
最後の方の話で 善友で他人と自分の境目がなく心配するっていうことと
あと世の中で言われているような
どちらかというと悪いことで
共依存 例えば人の世話をしないと生きていられないとか
自分と他人の境界がうまく境界のラインが引けないっていうこと
この 3つの区別がわからないのでお願いします
私もわからなくなっちゃって
もう一度 言ってみて  最初の方で慈しみの気持ちは OK だけど
愛着の気持ちはダメですっていうのが 1つ目で
最後の善友のいいことで
他人と自分の境界がなく
心配するのはいいことです
で  3つ目は えっと 世の中でよくダメって言われてる共依存っていうので
何依存？ 共依存 共に依存する
共依存  で よくアメリカとかでバウンダリーっていうことがすごく大事で
他人と自分との境界線を引きなさいと
そういうので それでその共依存というのはあんまりいいことじゃないっていう風に言われているんですけど
この 3つの区別がよくわからないのでお願いします
仏教で言った 2つは全然同じことな言葉変わっただけなんです
例えば友人関係どうするのかって
慈しみを実践すればそれで問題解決ですよ
例えば友人なら人間に限る
慈しみだったら全ての生命を慈しんでいるんだからね
そこら辺で具体的に好きなお人間がどんどん現れてくる
我々は野生の鳥たちも慈しむんだけど
一緒に生活しませんでしょうに
友達にもなりません だから
日本にいる全ての人間のことを幸福を願ってますけど
その中で一部の人間と一応付き合ってはいる
当たり前 単純なことでしょう
だから友情論を語る必要はない
本当は慈しみを語っちゃえばよかったとは思いますよ
だから慈しみで同じことなんですね
そこで専修の場合でもね
サマナソコドッカっていうね
専修がいて  3番目ですね
2番目  3番目 えーと だから苦楽を共にするというね
まあ別にそんな境界線とか何とかどうかね
そんなないでしょうに
なんで俺 いつでも原始的なアメリカの考えを持ってきて
こちらの大事な完全たる思考を破壊するんですかね
だからごちそう作ってあげるのに
その上に唾かけたり おしっこかけたりするなよと
それで私に聞くんですね
ごちそうですけど 豪華な料理ですけど
ちょっと唾かけてるんだからどうすればいいかと
だからこの西洋執行で適用できるものがあるなら
私は先に言います 慈悲がない世界で
慈悲の代わりに愛と言いますけど
愛も正しく理解してない世界で
自我を固執する世界で
すべて病気でしょ？自我故障したっても
助けてあげる人は助けてあげなくちゃいけない
それでそちらに問題が起こるんです
アメリカ人がもう自己主義で自我故障しているんだけど
もう火事になっちゃうとね
山火事になっちゃうと
みんな一緒に来てお互い助け合ってますよ
全然問題ないんです だから自然で生きれば生きていればいいのに
なんでそんなに自我を固執してしゃべるんですかね
アメリカ人といったっても
そんなに根っこから狂人じゃないんですよ
トランプさん以外は だからすぐ困ったらすぐ助けることあるんですよね
だからそこに自分の存在大事だ
自分の存在大事だと言っちゃうと
そこで問題が起こっちゃう
起こるんですね だからそれはそちらにある問題で
自分の他人の境界線という偉そうなことを言う必要はないんです
なぜならば いくらなんでも自分は自分だから
自分の心が別な流れで
他人の心と一緒に流れません
だからそちらに競争が成り立たないんです
心が依存型で依存しているだけなんです
例えば私の友達が瞑想して悟ったとする
私の戦友ですけど で 心は共にしているからといって
友達がどんどん悟りに達する
私も悟りに達する 達しないでしょうに
だからそれって普通でしょ
だからどうしても個人には個人の宿題があります
例えば最後に帰った苦楽を共にする友達が
友達が商売繁盛すると舞い上がって喜ぶ
でも自分も自分の商売しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
友達の商売繁盛で喜んで
それで終わっちゃうんだったら
自分がどうやって家族を養うんですかね
そういうことで ごく当たり前のシステムの中ですよ
だから個人にも個人の生き方がある
しかし 個人だといって殻を作るなよと
生命は共存で成り立っている
だからで 自分自身が消えるわけじゃないんです
自分の心の流れはすーっと一方的に流れているんです
しかし 心はどのように流れるのかというと
環境がそこで決めてしまうんですね
環境によって決められるんです
環境が決めるのではなくて
問題ないと私は思いますけどね
だから今日の話が間違って理解すると
瞑想して悟りに達する
達するような友達を作っちゃえば
自動的に自分も悟りに達するだろうという話になっちゃうんです
それはないんです はい
善友の中で友達が非難されていたら止めてあげるっていうところをもうちょっと教えてほしいんですけれども
確か鋸で切られても怒ってはいけないみたいな
経典の解説の中では お坊さんが別の比丘尼がなんかこう悪く言われていると
色をなして怒るっていうことに対して
お釈迦様がそういうことをしてはいけない
あなたはただ静かにしていなさいって言ったことがあるように思うのと
あと 全ての意見は見解は邪見なので
何を言われても聞き流した方がいいっていう風に
なんか私はそういう風に理解していたので
今日のそのお友達が非難されていたら止めてあげなさいっていうのをもうちょっと説明してもらえるとありがたいです
うーん 困りましたね だからこの友情論とは関係論ですから
だからこの そういう場合は生命
2人がいるでしょうに
だから関係論の場合は正しい関係を教えているんですね
だからまた仏道で自分を戒める教えがもっとたくさんなるしね
鋸のたとえで言っているのは
いかに自分自身を戒めるのかと
だから自分の自分の個人的な修行と関係の持ち方と 2つ分けて考えればね
友達がいるっていうこと
戦友がいるっていうことは
自分にはアドバイスしてくれる大事な存在がいる
エピソードで出てくるのは
感情的に付き合っていたことなんですよ
比丘尼たちやね 感情的にいろいろお坊さんたちに
それは仏教では戦友関係と思わないんですね
感情的な付き合いは断ちなさいとはっきり言ってますからね
だから感情的に付き合って
自分好きな人にのことを批判すると
幅が立ってしまう 自分も感情になっちゃうんですね
これは感情ではなく 理性の人間関係
理性の人間関係で 自分にとっては本当に役に立つ
ものすごい大事な欠かせない友達がいて
いつでもその人のおかげで自分が幸せで
その人を批判するとそうではないよと感情抜きに説明してあげることでしょう
おそらく 一応教え 2つですね
執着ない関係の結び方
関係の持ち方 結び方ではなく
それから自分の心の戒め方という 2つに分けて教えているところです
私たちによく出てくるのは
自分の戒め方の経典たくさんなんですね
しかし 基本的にお互い仏道では在家出家
みんな同じ仲間ということをお釈迦様はまず先程で入れているんです
あんた方は同じ仲間やと兄弟やと
在家の男女も出家の男女も兄弟やと
そこでお互いに心配する関係はまず入れてあるんですね
その上で一人一人が修行しなくちゃいけないっていう 2つの分け方なんです
よろしいです それ  お話の中で
日本人はことさら犀の角を
あのお経が日本人はことさら好きだということをお話があったのですが
日本人のそういう日本人が誤解をして
反社会的な意味で捉えてしまったっていうということだったのですが
長老から見て なぜ日本人がこの犀の角経にことさら惹かれるのか
どのような理由があると思われますか？ まあ
大したことないと思いますよ
だから現代社会っていうのは孤立した社会になってるでしょ
みんな一人一人生活してるんですね
いわゆる横の関係はどんどんなくなっているんですね
これは現代時代の問題なんですね
日本人は昔はもうたくさん
今も日本の田舎に行ったら
お互い話し合って挨拶し合って
心配し合って 状況を全部知っている
田舎に行ったら もう隣の人は何のこともダラダラと台所まで行くんだから
何のこともなく いまだにいまだに
あるいは自分が料理作っちゃって
知ってる友達にあげたければ
そのおばあさんが買い物に行く途中で人にあのね
なんだらかんだら連絡して
冷蔵庫に入れといてんだからね
持っていってと言う それだけ
その人は行って 人の家に入って
冷蔵庫を開けてちゃんと用意してある食べ物を持って帰るんです
だからそういう関係はまだちょっとね
田舎に残ってますから
だから田舎の日本人が犀の経典は好きにならないと思いますよ
だから都会の都会文化の現象ですね
これは一応一人でいるとなんとなく嫌なんですね
人間成長しませんね じゃあいいや
お釈迦様がおっしゃってるんだからねと決めちゃうんですね
反社会的でいいんだと
この連中付き合う必要ないやと
いうふうに調子に乗ってかかっているんですね
私はこの妄想だけで喋ってるんじゃ
いろいろ知ってるんだからね
経験があって その上でちょっと話を大げさにしているだけですけど
学者の方々もかなり犀の経典は素晴らしい
素晴らしいとは言ってるんですけど
その素晴らしいはみんな言ってるところで
一人で孤独で住めというところにあるわけじゃなくて
孤独とはすごい超越した
すごい真理のことを教えている言葉なんです
肉体的に一人で これ無理ですよ
そういうことだと思います
えーとですね 修行をしていて
少しだけこう 高い高い状態にパッと経験してですね
また下にドカンと落っこっちゃうっていうことが何回となくあったんですけども
それはどういった因果関係なのでしょうか
まあそれは ね  一時的に悪い心を作る原因がね
修行の結果でちょっと機能しなくなっちゃって
それでなんかすごい心が優れた状態になっちゃって
そこまた同じ条件が現れたらまた元に戻ってしまうんですね
だから 原因が足さない限りはね
そこは回転しますよ 時々経典でも真剣に集中して読んでいると
なんか自分自身も悟ったような錯覚を起こしちゃいますよ
よくわかっちゃってしまってね
それで後ですごい笑っちゃう
それってよくあること
これは注釈書でこういう例えあるんですよ
綺麗な湖がある しかし
水の上にこの何といいますか
浮草というんですか いろんな植物がいっぱい
苔とかね で そこで人が水を汲みたいんですね
飲むために そこでなんとか何とかして
上にある苔やら色々あちらこちらあちらこちらにして
綺麗な水をちょっと汲んじゃうの
汲んで釜を上げる瞬間にまたガクーンと元に戻しちゃうんです
で 修行する時でもそうやって時々苔が抜ける瞬間はありますね
だから原因が足すということがありますね
それはさらに進まなくちゃいけないんです
だから この清らかな状態がなんで起きたのかとかね
知って これ保せないのかどうかね
そこで頑張って色々研究していくと
さらに進むとは思いますね
はい  ありがとうございます
今日はありがとうございました
私は統合失調症なんですね
それで去年から瞑想を始めたら
去年で七錠薬が減りまして
今年になったらまた二錠減ったんですね
今八錠飲んでるんですけど
あと なんかヒステリックな弟にも瞑想を教えることができました
それで善友も私いる いるんですが
その善友が薬がなくなった時がスタートですよっておっしゃってくれたんですね
そして解脱をちょっと目指しているんですけど
何かアドバイスください
よろしくお願いします
あなたの善友が言ったことは正しいと思います
無理をしないでください
どんどん調子が良くなることをね
チェックしてチェックして
それでどんどん薬も自然に減ってね
無理に減っては減らしてはいけませんし
薬なくても大丈夫ということになったら
また自分をチェックして
どれぐらいこんな状態で持てるのかどうかね
そういう風に瞑想して
普通正常に心が働くようになってから
超越の方に行くという話ですね
だから 自然の流れに合わせて頑張ってください
はい  ありがとうございます
今日はお話ありがとうございました
最近 祖母と祖父が立て続けに亡くなって
で その代わりにお布施をしたいんですけど
その時のそのしきたりというか
こういうことは守ってお布施をしないといけないとか
そういうところをちょっとお聞かせいただきたいんですけども
うん まあそれって単純に心の問題なんですね
しきたりとかね 宗教の世界であるんだけど
本当は気にする必要ないんで
自分の気持ちの問題なんです
自分が本当に正直なそうな気持ちで
祖父が幸福になりますようにという気持ちで
善行為 何かお布施の善行為で
どんな善行為でもよろしいし
善行為してこの子だけで幸福になりますようにとね
素直に正直に思うことなんですね
それだけです だからしきたりないんです
凡々の世界でしきたりを欲しがってるだけのことですね
だから我々も何かしきたりなければちょっと気が済まないということもあるんですけど
まあやってもいいんだけど
やらないからといってどうったことはないんです
そんな程度です  午前中しかお布施をしたらいけないとか
ないないない ない 何もないんです
しきたりは  わかりました
ありがとうございます
こういうセミナーといいますか
こういうものを受けさせていただくとね
その時には いや 今日の話は大したことなかったなとかね
うん あの あんまり気づきが起きないことがあるんですね
ところが  2 日ぐらいすると急にあ
この間のやつはこれだったんだって気づきが起きたりするんですよ
いつもシャープにですね
瞬間瞬間気づきを起こす
起こさせるためには何が必要でしょうか
まあね やっぱりまああまり気にしない方がいいという単純な答えなんですけど
我々の性格もありますからね
だからそれは 1 日では変えられませんね
だから今おっしゃったことで
大したことはないね 今日の話っていうのは
その時はあまり集中力が入ってないし
内容は観察していない
それだけの後で思い出して考えたら
あ 大事なことがあったっていう風に気づくかも
それってご自分の心の流れなんですね
だからディスニーと私も思いますね
だから後で気づく方々は
話の内容を覚えておいて
あるいは録音でもしておいて
気が向いたら聞いてみると
半分半分と途切れ途切れでもよろしいし
一応私は私なりに工夫して喋ってますよ
かなり工夫してます だから途切れ途切れ喋っても
いつでも大事な表現は言ってるんですね
でも逆に そんなすごい大事なものがダラーッと並べちゃうと
心には入らないことも知っている
だからあの容器に水を入れたければ
ガーッと圧力かけて水を入れても
例えばジュリー10リットル入る容器がある 10
リットル入るでしょうに
ものすごい圧力で 1 秒で 10 リットル流れるホースで水を入れる
水が入ると思う？全然入りません
ただ濡れるだけ だからまあゆっくりと水がこぼれない状態で流れると一杯にはなりますね
そういうことだから 私はかなり強烈にスピーディに時間の範囲の中で喋っちゃいますから
もうそれは私の欠点でもありながらね
まあ仕方がないこともありますね
だからまあ後で気づいちゃってもいいんですよ
だから質問はちゃんとその場で理解するためにどうすればいいかってことなんですね
これ難しいんだけど フレーズ一つ一つに自分でその場でその場で宿題をするという方法はあるんです
私は若い時 勉強した時はそういうやり方なんです
授業を受けながら 脳の中で宿題をやるんです
忘れませんね 言ったことは
あ こういうことだからこうなってる
という風にちょっと宿題するんですね
喋ってるんだから微妙に時間がありますよ
だから集中するための
私個人的に知ってる解決はそれなんです
私は誰の話を聞いたってもね
今はないんだけど 人の話を聞くと
ちゃんとその場で その場で瞬間で宿題やってるんです
だから講義終わったら膨大な批判することもできるし
褒めることもできるし
もう彼が取り扱わなかったデータもこれこれあるんだよとも言えるし
結構できるようになっちゃうんです
それで難しいんだったら別にいいんじゃない？だからどこまで集中できるかっていうことでね
羨ましくはないんですよ
だからお釈迦様の時代でも同じことなんで
お釈迦様が説法するわするわするわ
全然理解しないお坊さんたちもいましたしね
お釈迦に叱られることもあったんだからね
ある人がずっとお釈迦様がいるところでウロウロしていて
なかなか理解してくれないんですね
最終的にもう年も取ったところで
もう後がなくなっちゃって
お釈迦様のところに来て
お釈迦様 本当に私はだらしないんだから
もう年も取ったんだからね
早く出世に出世するよう教えてください
それで その瞬間に真剣になった
お釈迦様が叱ったんだけど
あんたそんなこと言って若者はどう思いますかと
長く出家していて だらしないと言いながらも
じゃあ今日からこういう風にやってくださいと
彼にできることを教えたんですね
だからまあそんなもんでしょう
心は まあ大したことないと思っちゃってしまうし
すごい大事だと思ったりもするし
これって難しすぎてわからないと思ったりもするしね
その瞬間の心の状況なんですね
そういうことで あまり心配しないことですね
ありがとうございます
はい ではちょうど時間になりましたけど
はい では最後の聖団の
一緒に唱えましょう ドゥッカパッターチェニン
ドゥッカバヤッ パンターチェニンバヤ
スーカンパンターチェニッスーカ
ホントサンデーティパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
ありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナパラマンワダンティーブッダ
パーリ